dr. Peterson I have an interview for
medicine coming up very soon it's
structured in the MMI format and it's
intensely competitive any tips on how to
stand out from the rest
well the only thing I could say is that
two things one is really pay attention
to the interviewers write super
attention like don't glare at them like
you're aggressively paranoid but like
make sure you're focused on them and
then the other thing I would say is say
what you really think like tell the
truth it'll make you first of all if you
tell the truth and it doesn't work then
you know maybe that's not the school for
you that's something to really think
about and if it doesn't work anywhere
and you tell the truth maybe medicine
isn't for you and I know that might be a
terrible shock but let's assume that you
are genuinely properly motivated to
study medicine then tell them what you
think you know so many people when they
go into an interview try and they do
this when they write essays to is try to
tell the interviewers what you think
they want to hear but you can bloody
well be sure that virtually everybody
who's being interviewed is gonna do that
and I don't think that's very advisable
because if you don't manifest yourself
the way you are then there's no way that
the path that's proper for you can
reveal itself I know that sounds sort of
mystical but I don't know how to put it
any better the best way to stand out in
an interview always assuming you're
competent and that you've done the
preparation you know and that you're not
living a lie is to actually say what you
think and hopefully what will happen is
that there will be other people on the
panel that's this that are looking at
you who are of the same type and that
would characterize a good position for
you a good place to be if there are
people like that and they'll know what
you're doing and that will that would
then they'll think you know that person
you know they're there they'd be good
they're straightforward they're honest
they're they're tough they're they can
say what they think and if there aren't
people like that on the panel then I
would say you probably don't want to go
there anyways
so that's what I would that's what I
would do be true to yourself you know
but that also assumes that you've done
your homework and that you're prepared
in all of that because if you're a
useless jackass and you're yourself well
obviously that is going to work so good
luck good luck with your interview but I
always think that like the other thing
too is don't treat the interviewers as
enemies you know if that's hard because
if you're kind of petrified about the
potential outcome and you feel intense
judgment then you're likely to go in
there kind of afraid and nervous and and
maybe even resentful it's like you've
already done enough so that you're gonna
get interviewed so in some sense the
interviewers are hoping that you'll be
great already you know there might be
the odd cynic in there who's trying to
figure out a reason to give you an X and
check you off the list but most of the
people sitting there if they have a clue
are going to be looking for good
candidates and they're gonna assume that
you're you've hit threshold and so it's
not like they're not on your side and so
that's a good thing to keep in mind too
you're not going in there to face a
panel of enemies you're going in there
to face a panel of the sort of people
that you're likely to be in ten years so
that's another thing that's really
useful to keep in mind with interviews
in general I would say